after 34 years Tom Cruise returns as
maverick oh this is a competition film
about family friendship and sacrifice
it's a love letter to aviation we're
gonna show you what it's really like to
be a Top Gun pilot
you just can't create this kind of
experience unless you shoot it live in
order for us to accomplish this we have
the greatest fighter pilots in the world
working with us we're working with a
brand new camera system that allows us
to put six IMAX quality cameras inside
the cockpit with the actors it's amazing
what we see in the cockpit when an
audience is going to experience
the great amortization
thanks to Tom all the actors becoming
accustomed to g-forces by all the
training that they're doing that it is
aggressive
you can't act that the distortion in the
face they're pulling seven half a cheese
that's 1,600 pounds of force I am so
proud of them and what they've done and
it is heavy-duty
putting us up in these Jets it's very
serious that's why everybody thought it
would be impossible
and I think when Tom hears that
something is impossible or it can't be
done that's when he gets to work
flying while these fighter jets is an
absolute thrill right we want to make
sure that the audience has the same
experience
Aviation film like this has never been
done in Cheshire I will never be done
again
you